ein feuer brennt in die breite zu den
regeln botswana hey hallo leute hier ist
wieder einmal wanne und willkommen zu
einem neuen move und heute gibt es nach
langer zeit mal wieder sushi und gesa
mit gemüse füllung disclaimer an dieser
stelle wenn du nicht jemanden bei
anderen beim essen zu schauen kannst
dann solltest du jetzt lieber abschalten
für alle anderen viel spaß ich habe
riesen großen hunger ich habe lange
nicht mehr so viel gegessen aber für
diese special special situation habe ich
mir mal welches und er bestellt
sojasauce ich habe auf einen neuen laden
bestellt ich bin sehr gespannt
hier haben wir einmal aber carlo
greenpeace guten appetit
bitte was zu essen das alleine macht das
nicht so viel spaß wie mit mehreren ok
worüber möchte ich heute mit euch
sprechen
ich hatte ja das letzte längere lover
video war das wo ich instagram beendet
habe gelöscht habe beschluss von meiner
meinem handy jetzt seht ihr erst mal
wieder wie ich gar nicht reden kann und
das ist jetzt zwei wochen her drei
wochen
die sind nun schon her neunzehnter
dritter ist echt schon drei wochen her
vor drei wochen habe ich instagram
gelöscht und vermisse es seitdem keinen
einzigen tag
ich vermisse es schon zu wissen was so
michaela und kelly machen mehr fallen
mir endlich auch nicht ein von meinen
freunden haben nicht so viele leute dann
ist das toll gemacht aber die beiden und
das freut er sich schon zu wissen was
ich noch tun
aber das ganze andere man sich überhaupt
nicht ich fühle mich als ob ich niemals
diese app gehabt hätte manchmal wenn ich
meinen anderen beobachtet wie er sich in
stores oder so anschaut dann gucke ich
mal so rüber und bin so ein bisschen
interessiert so auch stimmt aber sonst
ich merke wirklich dass ich einfach mehr
zeit habe er sich entspannter bin ich
bin vielmehr konzentriert auf meine
videos vielleicht fällt euch ja auch als
für meine verhältnisse habe ich schon
viel gepostet die letzte zeit also fast
zu doch zwei wochen zwei videos die
woche schaffe ich mittlerweile und das
ist nicht gut für mich
das sind nach liebmann rettig wir machen
mal ein bisschen was aber hier drauf was
die challenge
das war super dumme idee ok
nie wieder wir haben eine liste gemacht
weil habe mir nämlich so ein kleines
schwarzes mit pittsburgh kaufte das
schreiben wir unser kleines blaues
möglichst buch ja das habe ich mir
gekauft weil ich merke dass ich oft am
tag
ideen habe sachen die mir einfallen und
weil ich sie nicht auf schreibe und auch
nicht mal mein handy irgendwie so da
habe und diese ganze notizen mehr waren
sind habe mir jetzt einfach dieses buch
geholt und jedes mal wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas schreibe ich das rein und
jetzt habe ich auch vor dem kurz
überlegt wohin rüber ich heute sprechen
möchte und dann hab ich mir das gleiche
in meinem buch geschrieben
instagram gelöscht darüber habe ich
schon gesprochen über organisation
wollte ich noch sehen ja dass quasi
dieses buch passt super zum thema
organisation bei das ist organisierte
dein leben mit einem schwarzen notizbuch
also in der schule hatte man ja immer
noch diesen kalender mit wo man nach
hause kam und so rein geschrieben hat
und das organisiert einfach schon gut
einleben
aber es ist irgendwie schwer wenn man
dann aus der schule raus ist und ja also
ich hab mir meine termine und so habe
ich mein handy kalender 1000 titel und
mir ist aufgefallen dass ich dieses
thema wirklich
also ich finde man ist heutzutage bei
uns also in unserer gesellschaft nur
etwas wenn du alles so super hinkriegt
wenn dein leben perfekt verläuft wenn
deine rechnung alle am ersten tag schon
bezahlt sind wenn du auch mails sofort
antwortet und einfach so dieser perfekte
mensch liest und ich finde aber man ist
halt mehr als das und man da kann auch
also ich bin auch perfekt so wie ich bin
das klingt so hoch aber ich mache alles
nach meinem tempo ich mache meine
organisation so wie ich schaffe ich gebe
jeden tag mein bestes aber manchmal ist
es besser halt einfach auch nicht super
gut und ich finde man sollte auch an
solchen tagen also sagen okay dann ist
es halt nicht immer gut
ich bin halt auch ultra vergessen ich
überhaupt keine lust mehr in meinem
alter noch irgendwie darüber ja weiß ich
nicht ich finde man sollte sich nicht so
stressen und nicht sich jemand diese
perfekten beispiele nehmen von leuten
die das halt irgendwie perfekt
hinkriegen super organisiertes leben zu
haben und also bei den muss immer alles
aufgeräumt sein sohn sind ja auch im
kopf gar nicht klar
ja in der theorie klingt es voll cool
aber wer hat den zeit ständig so oft
freuen das ist mir den kopf klar werden
kann
bei mir sieht es nicht jeden tag so aus
nur welchen videodreh dann heute ich mit
euch noch über diese youtube glocken
es ist ja so man kann auf youtube einen
kanal abonnieren und dann sollte youtube
die das in dieser abonnenten liste
vorschlagen
also wenn ich zum video hole amateure
und das ist aber nicht mehr so ganz der
fall
youtube macht das irgendwie nicht mehr
so regelmäßig schon mal einigen die
meine videos zum beispiel regelmäßig
schauen bei anderen dann aber wieder gar
nicht weil sie sich ein paar wochen wie
es nicht angeschaut haben sagte
algorithmus von youtube alles klar du
interessiert sich nicht mehr für die
videos wir werden nicht damit auch nicht
mehr nehmen und das ist ein super schade
weil klar kann einer von euch sagen kay
den letzten wochen fand ich mal war halt
einfach doof aber das heißt ja nicht
dass es nicht anders ist später dann
wieder nicht verändert meine videos
verändern sich auch und da kommen wir
jetzt zu dieser blöden glocke die hier
am anfang hat sie eingeführt wurde
damit die überhaupt nicht ernst genommen
ich kann das auch so komisch als am
anfang sich so viele youtuber also als
sie in videos gesagt haben ja und bitte
aktiviert die glocke reichen mir dachte
ist auch abonniert das reicht doch
aber nehmen die glocke zeigt diesem
youtube algorithmus jetzt ich möchte
wirklich diese videos sehen dann kann
man auch in dieser glocke entscheiden
möchte ich alle videos vorgeschlagen
kriegen oder nur einige ja man bekommt
sie dann auch aufs handy das weiß ich es
auch schon ziemlich nervig ich finde
aber extrem schade wenn ich ein kanal
abonnieren wenn ich die videos wirklich
nicht mehr mag und auch gar nicht mehr
sehen möchte dann abonniere ich kanäle
das habe ich schon oft gemacht aber wenn
ich einen youtube-kanal gut finde aber
gerade irgendwie nicht wahr weil sie
gerade nicht die videos schauen möchte
will ich aber trotzdem dass mir die
videos gezeigt werden einfach auch zu um
zu wissen ob die erhält auch weitermacht
ich finde nämlich es geht so schnell
dass man im youtube-kanal abonniert
mit dem schießen und so voll dass man
einen youtube-kanal abonniert und dann
die videos aber nicht mehr vorgeschlagen
werden und man dann völlig vergisst dass
man diesen youtube-kanal abonniert hat
ich weiß nicht wirklich viele kanäle ich
abonniert habe ich glaube 50 oder mehr
so viel mehr aber andere leute haben zum
beispiel die 200 oder so und da vergisst
man halt schon also denkt ihr morgens an
mich denkt ihr morgens musste vanessa
was macht dir oder instagram wisst ihr
das nicht mehr
tata tata und deswegen sollte es
eigentlich nicht so sein dass man die
glock aktivieren muss aber wenn ihr
wollt dass meine videos euch weiter
vorgeschlagen werden wäre es echt gut
von euch wenn ihr diese glocke aktiviert
weil man auch durch diesen algorithmus
von youtube landet man schnell in so
einen kreis das wenn leute weniger wird
also wenn dein bios weniger geschaut
werden schlägt youtube sie weniger vor
und dadurch werden sie halt wieder
weniger geschaut weil youtube sie halt
nicht so viele werden vorschlägt und das
kann in so ein kreislauf gehen dass man
halt wirklich eine zeit lang auch wenn
der content gut ist auch in die leute
ist eigentlich feiern dass man einfach
weniger aufrufe macht und weniger
dadurch verdient und es ist ja unser job
und wenn ich meinen job nicht mehr
bezahlt werde dass er es halt scheiße
also aktivierten ecke und werdet ein
teil der waschbecken army was steht denn
noch in meinem schlauen notizbuch
russland ich hoffe ihr ein schönes
ostern
ich hoffe euch bitte ein bisschen
gefeiert oder ihr habt eure familie
gesehen oder eigentlich irgendwas
besonderes ist einnimmt da passiert ich
bin über ostern nach hause gefahren und
habe mit meiner familie gefeiert
meine mutter die wohl beste köchin der
welt hat ein essen rausgehauen
was so gut es gab große kartoffeln und
sie macht auch mal so ein reich mit so
einer rosin soße klingt vielleicht auf
den ersten momenten nicht so lecker aber
die so rosin soße es glaube ich mein
absolutes lieblingsgericht von ihr
natürlich das auf live und so und ich
war auch da weil ich an
bei meinem bruder geburtstag bin ich
auch über gefahren
hamburg und dann hat mein bruder
mercedes er aus 187 konzert geht
87 jetzt werden nicht ganz viele hassen
und dann habe ich gesagt ja klar ich
komme mit hab voll bock drauf und dann
ist mir jetzt einen gefallen als ich das
schon gekauft habt das ist einfach ein
oster lösungen war das auch so ein
bisschen zwei fliegen mit einer klappe
sehr gut an sondern das 187 konzert
gegangen
an ostern also samstag
und es war einfach diese barg war barg
art wie hey sie die arena in hamburg
meine eltern sagen immer hakan ali akbar
khan
barkley war katharina irgendwie so eine
12.000 menschen 12.000 187 fans hätten
das konzert es war wirklich ein sehr
gutes konzert ich habe mich sehr
amüsiert lag auch an mein bruder ich mag
ihn sehr gerne und ich mag zeit mit
ihnen verbringt und ja das war ein sehr
witziger abend und ich fand's einfach
mir ja lustig bei 187 an russland zu
sein als ob ich habe ganz interessant
activity für kinder gespielt meine
lichte und ich wir hatten echt eine gute
zeit also activity wie kinder macht viel
mehr spaß als das activity für wachsende
weil bei den kindern
hast du zwar einfache begriffe wie wurst
und so aber bei und und da hat ein paar
schwierige wie räuber gruppe oder sowas
wo man schon überlegen muss was man
machen das aber ich finde bei dem
richtigen activity ist dass
radioaktivität hat manchmal so komische
begriffen ja das ist auch der spielspaß
dass man es nicht sofort geschafft aber
ich fand das sehr cool komplex
hingefahren fahrzeugs interessiert und
es ist verrückt mit dem flex bus fährst
du für fast 30 10 euro von berlin nach
hamburg und meine eltern wohnen in der
nähe von buxtehude und dann musst du für
dieses ticket von hamburg nach buxtehude
sieben euro 40 oder so zahlen
das heißt bezahlt für diese kurze
bahnfahrt also 50 minuten oder sind sind
das fast so viel wie viel scheiß
busticket von berlin nach hamburg was
nicht heißt dass das bahnticket ultra
teuer ist ich glaube halt das also ich
verstehe nicht wie man für 10 euro von
berlin nach hamburg fahren kann wie
rentiert sich das also wo ich verstehe
die systemisch wie wie flex bus daran
geld verdienen kann
wahrscheinlich weil die busfahrer kaum
geld kriegen wir die mitarbeiter kaum
geld kriegen aber das kannst du nicht
nur sein oder die heimat war schön es
ist immer wieder schön nach hause zu
fahren ich denke mir jedes mal wenn ich
also ich von der großstadt berlin gehört
ist denn jetzt eigentlich gar nicht gibt
es eine größere stadt in deutschland als
berlin schreibt wenig um darwin jetzt
bist und es ist jedes mal super
erfrischend runter zu hoch
berlin/hamburg hochzufahren und aufs
dorf zu fahren weil wenn ich darf im
dorf bin und immer einmal auf meinen
markt mit meinem kaffee es waren lieder
vom ordentlicher das ist kapital
wenn ihr mal im norden seit dem kapital
ist der beste bäcker land der welt wenn
du dann auf dem marktplatz sitzt und es
so schön ruhig ist und alles ach ja weil
sie nicht du fährst die filme entwickeln
ring ich will mal kurz wer jedoch lieber
fürs dorf gemacht es gibt vielleicht
nicht doch zu viel
berlin ich liebe dich aber manchmal
merkt man nicht wie anstrengend das ist
wenn man aus der haustür kommt und ab
dem moment im griff seine haustür
draußen bist schon dieses hektischen
leben losgeht ist nicht in allen teilen
berlin so natürlich nicht
im inner circle sage ich mal mehr los
ist
aber es ist halt schon schön anstrengend
manchmal andererseits wusste ich gar
nicht mehr auf was ihr vom dorf machen
sollten
ich mag mich so gerne auto fahren da
bisher auf dem dorf ist schon
aufgeschmissen meldungen mussten auto
haben und da sind so wenig leute alle
meine freunde von früher gitarren sind
umgezogen sind wir studierenden anderen
städten oder im boden ausbildung gemacht
mit ist da keiner mehr
also weiß ich nicht wenn wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch schnell langweilig
ich habe mir noch eine sache notiert und
zwar dass das das letzte detail ist um
so schnell geht's vorbei sagt gute nacht
ach so ich möchte gerne dazu was sagen
ich habe moschee zum nachricht besteht
es kommt in so einer riesen
plastikverpackung nochmal in plastik
verpackt zu sein
das ist ja ok aber dass ich glaube ich
privat das irgendwie auch als dose oder
so es ist so schade
ich würde echt gern weniger müll
produzieren
es gibt viele dinge die einfach müll
machen man muss dann halt schon wenn man
wirklich auch wenn wilde zu produzieren
dann muss man auch seine elektrische
zahnbürste falten oder es schon gut weil
es ja nicht so viel machen ich weiß
nicht wer so holz zahlen müssen
in dieser moschee sieht
einzigartig aus was ist das es war und
hart
moshi ist so reiskuchen mit bohnen pasta
gefüllt ist das leckerste jetzt nicht
mehr
das ist halt so ein fertigteil 23 euro
gekostet wir sind ja dass sie selbst
gemacht sind die meisten sind immer
selbst gemacht weil das wäre ja nicht so
gut es entwickelte sich zum ethik smoke
bank der welt
hey mein name ist vanessa ich hole mal
einen anderen nach des jahres gleich das
ist doch ein genetisch für gewinner 1
kirsch schoko saucen joghurteis mit
einer kirsche obendrauf
es ist nämlich so willig ist
wusstet ihr dass die kirche aber auch
diese soße aus dem glas dass sie bei mir
um die ecke also aus meiner heimat kommt
bitteschön für diesen zweck das war
jetzt die ersten tage warm und können
wir das sofort an meine motivation habe
ein kirschkern man sofort in eine
motivation hat für mich richtig waschen
geladen und das letzte was er hungrig
mit euch reden wollte ist youtube die
ich gerade schauer und euch wärmstens
empfehlen wenn ihr aufmuckt gang bangs
steht so richtig im klassischen sinne
da müsst ihr euch auf jeden fall emi
anfahren km
um welchen youtuber ich glaube gerade
die am meisten charles shane dawson also
seine videos sind ultra lang ein
bisschen wie durch mediation geworden
also so wie alle ttv mäßig aber super
lustig und schaue jetzt so gerne an der
marwitz und sind wir der logical
natürlich ich habe mir einen
französischen canal an den verlinkt ich
euch unten nicht französisch aber sind
von so sein und die machen so fashion
videos und ich mag ihre art wie sie
redet die rede so ruhig und entspannt
wenn man mehrere bio seien schaue bin
ich danach so eine also ruhig innerlich
plan und los ihr solltet auf jeden fall
mein kanal auschecken wenig mit funk
zusammen mache und mit jonas und lisa
belanglos findet ihr auch unten
ich finde aber auch diese mode bank sind
auch irgendwie so ein podcast oder
sollte mir fällt anfangen mit bahngäste
zu holen mit denen ich dann zusammen
essen kein wahrscheinlich voll kamera
essen wir mittlerweile impuls bringen
aber ich habe mittlerweile so viel vor
der kamera gemacht also ich merke gar
nicht mehr den unterschied ob die kamera
an ist oder nicht
wir sagen dass ich ihn so in großen
räumen mit so vielen leuten bin ist mir
egal ob die kamera läuft
das war früher nicht so ich das video
gefallen hat können wir den kanal
abonnieren
und ansonsten findet ihr hier daran
videos und bis zum nächsten mit barren
anderem video
ich habe euch jetzt gefallen wenn ihr
themen habt über die ich das beim
nächsten coup bahn reden soll wo ihr
wirklich sagt eines hat das interessiert
mich thema aus darüber schreibt die
kommentare
ich habe auch eine gute meinung zu allen
themen auf dieser welt also es lohnt
sich
bis zum nächsten mal